[Music]
thank you
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
okay economy returns to growth in April
helped by shopping and nights out
shell to cut spending in coming years
while giving more to its shareholders
why generative AI could add more than
four trillion dollars to annual Global
productivity Plus
cold shower falling off my roof and my
heels
are on the ground
[Applause]
from Toy to screen I'll be speaking with
the chief executive of Mattel about
Barbie the movie
foreign
King live in our business and economic
news from the Heart of the City the UK
economy returned to growth in April on
the back of an expansion in the services
sector following a week March but I've
put in production and Manufacturing both
declined during the month well the
office office for National statistics
says that her growth came in for April
at 0.2 percent that followed a
contraction of 0.3 percent during March
according to the ons growth over the
three months to April was 0.1 percent
well this morning the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt said that while he was positive
about the economic Outlook tackling
inflation remained his top priority
well today's figures confirm what the
oecd said last week the IMF said last
month the bank of England themselves
have said that there is underlying
resilience in the British economy and of
course that's positive but we still have
a big issue with inflation that is the
number one challenge we Face we have to
do everything we can as a government as
a country to support the bank of England
in their mission to squeeze inflation
out of the system and that is our
primary focus
well joining me now is the chief UK
Economist at Capital economics Paul
Dales Paul welcome to you I'm in the
March figure uh was unusually weak due
to the weather is this just a bounce
back from that or is there more to it do
you think
there's a bit more to it to that but it
has to do with strikes actually rather
than the weather so um there are a lot
of uh train and teacher strikes in March
um which didn't happen in April so
activity in those sectors transport and
education rebounded however on the flip
side
um there were a lot of Junior doctor
strikes in April which did drag down
activity but the bigger Point here is
that the economy so far has proved
reasonably resilient and hasn't yet born
into a recession
that is the magic word resilience Paul
why do you think it is I mean every CEO
I speak to says things have gone much
better this year than we expected why do
you think that is the case
well I think there's a couple of factors
um the first is that households seem to
have been able to dip into what you
might call their pandemic savings any
any slush funds they built up during the
pandemic when they weren't able to go
out and spend and the second is actually
the government has dished out a lot of
money to many households and businesses
over the last year to cope with the big
rise in Energy prices and that's really
helped
um so essentially the UK economy has
managed to get through what you might
call the cost of living crisis without a
recession The Next Step though is what I
think we can call the cost of borrowing
crunch now that I think is what lies
ahead of us yeah absolutely I mean just
before came on I was reading some tweets
from Nick McPherson the former permanent
secretary at the treasury and he says he
thinks now there's a real danger now the
bank of England is going to have to
raise interest rates so high effectively
the UK goes into a recession
I agree with that yes we've been saying
that at Capital economics for a while
um the problem with the economy actually
being uh quite resilient it means that
the labor market is quite strong as we
saw in some data released yesterday
which is generating this inflationary
pressure
um that the bank of England needs to get
hold of
um so I think interest rates are going
to have to rise from four and a half
percent now to perhaps five and a
quarter percent in the coming months and
that uh together with the rise has
already seen
um suggests to me that uh households
will just have to pay more for their
borrowing for their mortgages and as a
result the UK will fall into recession
later this year
now the bank of England's monetary
policy committee meets again uh tomorrow
week most people assume that there'll be
another rate rise so I guess the big
question is whether it's uh a quarter
point or a half a point
well that's right I mean three weeks ago
there was a question of whether there'd
be a rate rise at all
um but now a quarter point seems nailed
on I think there's some chance of a 50
basis point hike so that would be a half
percentage Point increased to five
percent
um but my money's on a a couple of
quarter steps really
um so we go to 4.75 on the bank of
England Maine interest rates next week
and then there's two more hikes after
that to five and a quarter
um but in all honesty a lot of this
effect is already coming through because
we've seen in the last couple of weeks
mortgage lenders are pulling their uh
best fixed rate deals and putting new
ones out with much higher interest rates
so households are starting to feel this
and this was going to be a constant
theme throughout the next six to 12
months Paul Woody Reflections on what
we've seen in the guilt Market this week
the market in UK government bonds
because obviously for example yesterday
the two-year yield hit its highest level
since the global financial crisis I mean
this uh has a big uh implicit increase
in government borrowing costs
yes it does indeed
um so that is the the main effect on the
government is that they'll have to pay
more
um to borrow from uh the financial
markets and in some ways that takes
money out of the economy
um
I I'm not too worried about that and the
government can cope with that um what I
think is more worrying is um the
increases in Guild yields are feeding
through into higher mortgage rates for
households
um that's I think is where the pain is
going to be felt
um and uh that's where the real weakness
is going to come through it's worth
saying um although we think there's
going to be a recession I don't think
this is going to be a huge recession I
don't think it's going to be a deep one
I don't think it's going to be a long
one
um but I think it is too soon to
conclude that just because the economy
is done reasonably well over the last
year that it's going to avoid a
recession over the next year
Paul for the benefit of viewers who
don't necessarily uh be okay with how
these things work I mean Andrew Bailey
the the bank of England Governor has
said recently that he felt only a third
of the rate Rises so far have actually
been transmitted through to the real
economy on that basis why is the bank
still raising interest rates some people
might say well why can't they just wait
to let the the rate hikes take their
course
that is one option and there's a couple
of people on the bank of England's
monetary policy committee who have taken
that view and have not voted to raise
interest rates over the past few months
so that is is a reasonable view to take
um the problem is
um in my view is that once inflation is
high and people see it being high then
businesses and households get used to
the idea of it being high and I think
you need to actually raise interest
rates quite sharply
um to create a little bit of economic
weakness to convince households and
businesses that inflation is going to
come back down if you take the foot off
the break too early then essentially
inflation is just going to run away and
run away and it just there's a bigger
danger that it becomes embedded in
people's expectations instead of people
assuming that inflation is going to be
two percent they might assume it's going
to be three or four percent and then to
get inflation down once that's happened
is really hard and you need to generate
even more economic so it's probably the
case actually that with interest rates
it's best to go a little bit too far now
just to make sure you really really get
inflation down because that is going to
mean for households and businesses
they're going to be in a better place in
a couple of years time if inflation is
around two percent rather than four
percent
all right Paul we have to leave it there
good to talk to you as ever this morning
thank you very much thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and shell said this morning that it
will be cutting its spending during
coming years while handing back a
greater proportion of its earnings to
shareholders well the oil major said it
would cut its spending in 2024 and 2025
to between 22 billion and 25 billion US
dollars per year that's down from
between 23 billion to 27 billion dollars
this year at the same time between 30
and 40 percent of cash flow from
operations will be returned to
shareholders compared with 20 to 30
percent previously this will include a
15 rise in the dividend well the
announcement represents an effort by
Charles new chief executive while Sawan
to restore shareholder confidence amid
unease over the company's energy
transition plan Mr Sawan confirmed that
shell plans to hold oil production
steady between now and 2030 while
insisting it remains On Target to become
a net zero emissions energy business by
2050.
shares of Robert Walters fell by more
than 15 this morning after the
recruitment agency warned the profits
for the year would be significantly
below expectations the company said that
reduced levels of candidate confidence
and lengthening time to hire which began
in the second half of last year had not
started to improve it said its net fee
income during April and May had been
down 10 on those months last year but
the company insisted the tight labor
market meant that when Market confidence
recovered there would likely to be a
return to meaningful growth
and the fantasy Miniatures and
collectibles group Games Workshop said
this morning it expects to post an
annual profit of at least 170 million
pounds this year up from 157 million
pounds a year ago the maker of Warhammer
said it expected sales for the Earth to
the 28th of May would come in at not
less than 440 million pounds up from 387
million pounds during the previous 12
months it said that during the year it
had handed employees bonuses totaling 11
million pounds up from 10 million pounds
in the previous 12 months and that works
out at more than four thousand pounds
per employee the shares are currently
ahead by just over four percent
now one of the main talking points in
the tech sector and Beyond just now is
the extent to which generative AI
applications like chat GPT have the
potential to transform economies few
people have tried until now to put a
figure on that but today a new report
published by the consultancy McKinsey
and Company suggests that generative AI
could add between 2.6 trillion and 4.4
trillion US dollars worth of annual
productivity globally well joining me
now is Lorena Yee she's senior partner
and chair of the McKinsey Technology
Council Lorena good to see you this
morning I mean this estimate is based on
the 63 new generative AI use cases as
you call them give me a few examples if
you would please
all right let's take all of our jobs the
job that you're doing right now how do
you prepare for this um how do you
decide marketing scripts for campaigns
how do you think about drug Discovery a
super set of jobs are going to see
superpowers attached to them with
generative Ai and so we looked at these
63 use cases and what we really did was
we dug into the anatomy of work we
looked at 850 jobs in the global economy
and broke those down into 2 100
activities and said how will generative
AI impact each of these activities and
what we found is that 70 percent of the
global Workforce we'll see up to 50
percent of their work activities
impacted by gender of AI I mean that is
a stunning number and it's really
through looking at how work changes that
we get to some of these big numbers like
4.4 trillion dollars of productivity I
was going to say it's quite a difficult
thing to try and estimate the uh the
value potential in those use case cases
it absolutely is and one of the things
that we have to understand is what we
were laying out is the full potential
what does that look like and what we're
really looking at are two things we're
looking at the impact of the automation
technologies that we already have today
and we're also looking at the added
impact of generative AI which is just
broken fast into the scene over the last
six months but one other thing that's
really important is this isn't just
about technology this is about people
and this is really a leadership moment
as Leaders particularly in the business
Community we have a choice on how fast
we Lean Forward on this trend what this
report shows is the economic potential
what we will actually see depends on our
business decisions and how we actually
make those decisions going forward
that's a really key point that you've
made I mean all of this ultimately
depends on how rapidly businesses can
adopt this technology
absolutely and that's not just a cost
technology capability question that's a
choice about how do you want to think
about the workforce of the future and
let me just give you a concrete example
if we can save 50 of the time of your
time and my time as knowledge workers
want to do with that productivity
Surplus do we want to give it back in
terms of time to you and I maybe have a
four day work week do we want to drop it
down to the bottom line and give it to
our shareholders to the CFO or do we
want to rethink how work is done and
actually spend more time at the things
that humans are uniquely capable of
doing which is human connection and
interaction so there are a lot of
choices that we have in front of us I
think adopting the technology is just
the first step
I think when you talk about a four-day
working week a lot of people will see
that as a positive given all the
concerns over the number of jobs it will
potentially destroy
well I think what's really important is
this report is not about destroying jobs
this report is saying how can generate
Ai and other automation Technologies
affect how we work now that could be and
in most cases what we're seeing is that
augments our job it gives us superpowers
in how we work day to day and in the
early business cases and how we see
leaders responding to this most of what
we're seeing so far is augmentation and
humans at the center of things but we
will see these are business decisions
that we need to make
now one of the sectors that you think is
going to be most impacted is banking why
is that
well one of the things is when we looked
uh just to geek out with you when we
looked at the 63 use cases and we said
how does that affect different functions
the vast majority of it were really
knowledge workers sales and marketing
jobs software engineering R D
um these were a lot of the jobs that
were most impacted by generative Ai and
if we look at a bank there are a lot of
people with these jobs so think about
wealth managers think about the large
I.T and software enablement they have
and so that's really one of the reasons
that banking is is certainly affected we
also see banking as a sector that's
leading on generative AI there are some
fantastic early use cases of thinking
differently about how to
synthesize information for wealth
managers and how they can actually spend
more of their time with their clients
and less of their time analyzing and
drafting materials
Lorena it's a fascinating report thanks
very much for coming on to discuss it
today thank you
now recent figures suggest that the UK
is the fifth most popular destination
for foreign direct investment around the
world attracting more than two trillion
dollars worth of investment in 2022
alone we tend to think that investment
largely in the UK comes from U.S
companies like Ford or more recently
Indian companies like Tata but before
them both was Bosch the engineering car
parts and appliances group this year
celebrates its 125th year in the UK it
was the first country in which it opened
outside its native Germany it now
employs around five and a half thousand
people throughout the UK and Ireland who
are joining me now I'm very pleased to
say is Bosch's Global chief executive Dr
Stefan Horton hey doctor welcome to you
um Robert Bosch did play a crucial role
in establishing the UK Karl Mark making
sector how big a role though is Auto in
your UK business these days
all that still has a major role that's
for sure we are also active in consumer
Business Industrial business but still
the auto business is key and it's also
key for the UK and obviously that's our
interest that the automotive business in
the UK is flew under running with our
customers and partners over there and
also the edge of technology which is in
Ai and automated driving that's what we
also do in the UK and that's also where
we have invested in the UK and over the
last two years we mentioned it's about
600 million we put in which shows that
we think in the UK is a good location to
be and which are the main priorities for
for that investment
well we put some money into a a small
company that is dealing with AI
applications for automated driving and
we bought hydroforce which is an
industrial company dealing with
hydraulics which has its headquarter in
the UK and that brings us now to a 6 700
people operation in the UK and I would
say are continuously growing because
even in the situation we are right now
we didn't have so much growth in the
last year because of the shrinking
consumer business but a very uh
substantial growing Automotive business
we had about a three billion pounds
operation in the UK and with our history
I think we want to go on
very interestingly I think you're
targeting Global sales growth this year
of between six and nine percent you're
already running ahead of that here in
the UK
well a bit yes but we have to be careful
about forecast for that year I still
hope that the 69 in total will be
reachable and also the UK will be
superseding this but on the other end we
all know that the economic conditions
are not easy to to analyze right now I
think we will still see some weakness in
the consumer business but I'm betting on
that people need to buy some cars which
I couldn't Buy in the last year so I
think there will also be strong growth
drivers also in the UK
we've just been speaking to our previous
guest about generative Ai and the
productivity improvements it can push
through potentially what are you doing
on that front
well the foundational models were a huge
breakthrough which we actually
experienced now week by week you have to
think about that six months ago nobody
was really talking about this and now we
see it in application even on our
private phones and that's a major
breakthrough because that will now bring
a productivity wave in the jobs which
deal with language for example or with
pictures and guess what that's all the
jobs we do and we will reach
productivity gains which are substantial
in the next years and I absolutely
believe the numbers which have just been
mentioned by McKinsey the key is now to
find the right applications fast enough
in businesses as well as in applications
for consumers to gain these
productivities because that's the major
point of this to gain productivity with
these generated AI tools
and implicit in that I guess is a degree
certainly of upskilling for for
employees
well the good thing on the foundational
models they are very easy to use
actually what we're seeing is something
which is traumatic for the AI business
so far I I was something for super
Specialists right people with phds long
years education mathematicians and
Specialists that's what we still have so
we we have uh many hundreds of those
people working for us on the other hand
what we see with the foundational models
now it's kind of a democratizing of AI
models
um for everybody and that's what you see
also on platforms like GitHub where a
lot of programmers worldwide which are
not AI Specialists are now applying AI
in a wider scale so I think the up
scaling of knowledge is actually made
easier with it and AI would be much
easier to apply
now more broadly we learned last week
that the Eurozone economy has slipped
into recession albeit on a very shallow
basis is that affecting investment
decisions you're making and how you're
approaching running the business in the
second half of the year
well the second half of here I hope that
we see some of these effects not coming
as dramatic as we thought and that's all
we foreseeable that's caused by a good
thing and a bad thing right on one hand
we see that some of the interest rate
hikes which are necessary to fight
inflation are now postpone a bit or put
a bit on a stop which is on one hand
probably positive for this year so maybe
some growth Dynamic will be a bit better
than it was forecasted about six months
ago where we strongly thought that a
recession is coming and maybe even the
UK you saw that is is getting by that
and it's not hitting your session uh
Germany is in a recession and it's a
shallow one not a deep one but there is
one and we have to get out of this on
the other hand that that less aggressive
work on interest rates but the central
banks could lead to a further
prolongation of the inflation scenario
and that's obviously not a good use so
that's bringing further risk for 2024.
so I see a mixed bag right now I would
say we stay on the plan and continue to
invest in our growth areas and
transformation but definitely the waters
are not easy to read
now the German government is forging
ahead at the moment with a ban on new
gas boilers as of the beginning of next
year it's proving very unpopular in
Germany is it causing you much of a
headache
well we are on the gas boiler business
you know that also in the UK with
booster we are one of the major players
in the UK for gas boilers and also in
Europe with woodyros and Yonkers
um these car spawners are
um all to be hydrogen ready uh very soon
right so that everybody who buys a gas
book can transform it to a hydrogen gas
boiler which is absolutely CO2 free and
that's also now in the German regulation
um got a footprint because in the first
regulation concept we saw at the gas
bottle was pretty much banned right it
was not seen as anything where it can be
useful in the CO2 neutral scenario of
the future on the other hand it's clear
that we will have a hydrogen economy and
we will need it and we have huge gas
infrastructures and the UK has one of
the best gas grids worldwide reaching
pretty much every household and similar
also in some areas of Germany so the
question will be which technology which
is CO2 free will be the best one and
you've seen the current regulationary
setup which is discussed as we speak it
will go into Parliament maybe this week
or next week and then discussions will
go on this is much more technology open
and I would as a technology person say
let's keep things technology open as
long there are CO2 neutral but that will
show in the next decades then what's the
best solution for each area of the world
there's probably not one there's many
now more broadly also you've been
investing recently in chip manufacturing
capability in the United States what's
informed that decision is it concerns
over Security in Taiwan
where the chip Investments we do are are
strategic because our chip business is
in special areas we are not a giant ship
manufacturer by size we are specialized
we do A6 which is special chips for some
Automotive applications and also some
consumer applications we need for our
products mostly made for ourselves then
we have a sensor business which is a
broad business for all kinds of consumer
devices so many of the consumer devices
you use have these tiny mining micro
sensors in them and that's what we do
and obviously we're working on the power
conversion Technologies this is the
silicon carbide technology for example
which you use for electric vehicles this
technology is very important to get
these vehicles more efficient longer
duration of run less battery size so
that's bringing a lot of economics and
for this we bought a facility in the US
and and in TSI to build a silicon
carbide Factory over there and ramp it
up and that's definitely I think a good
way to go because silicon carbide will
be the essence of electric cars next to
batteries
hey doctor great pleasure to catch up
with you again this morning thanks very
much indeed for speaking to me
appreciate it thanks a lot
[Music]
last night Strong finish on Wall Street
on the back of benign U.S inflation data
was followed by mixed trade overnight
for equities in the Asia Pacific region
here's the State of Affairs Hong Kong
and Shanghai in negative territory
you'll note that in the top left-hand
corner of the screen the Nikkei in Tokyo
hit another 33 year high well in Europe
this morning stocks have literally
largely been trading to the upside ahead
of the uh key interest rate decision
tonight from the US Federal Reserve
that's the current picture all of the
main Continental European indices in
positive territory right now talking
points this morning include Casino
shares of the debt Laden French
Supermarket have surged by 15 and a half
percent in Paris that's after a
Consortium of business people made a 1.1
billion Euro takeover approach well here
in London it's a bit flatish by
comparison the ftse 100 is up a third of
one percent right now consumer stocks
are dragging on the index to an extent
the leading Blue Chip gainer in
percentage terms this morning is the
tool and plant rental group Ash dead the
shares are head right now by a further
two and three quarter percent that was
on the back a very strong trading update
for the company put out yesterday on the
downside well there was an after hours
announcement last night from the gaming
group entertain the owners of course of
Ladbrokes and coral they're buying a
Polish gaming group called STS for 750
million pounds there's a big share issue
to go with that to fund that acquisition
and entain shares are accordingly off by
some 10 this morning outside the ftse
well leading midcap gainers right now is
Games Workshop and mentioned them a
little early on the shares up four
percent on that trading update well with
air as you can see on the screen there
up by nearly three and a quarter percent
that is on positive broker comment the
broker is really warming to this one
right now on the downside the used car
dealer motor point it Shares are off by
some three percent right now that's
after higher financing costs pushed it
into a full year loss meanwhile The
Specialist Plastics firm victrex its
Shares are off by some uh five percent
right now on a profits one morning they
were down seven percent earlier on on
the foreign exchange markets for the
pound yesterday hit its highest level
for a month against the US Dollar on the
back of the Punchy wages data it's
Consolidated those gains this morning
Sterling up another fifth of one percent
against the Greenback it's up at 10 10th
of one percent against the Euro The
single currency meanwhile is up a tenth
of one percent against the dollar as for
the oil price well that rallied last
night for the first time in five
sessions and again it's Consolidated
those gains this morning about a
breakthrude will currently set you back
75 dollars one cent a barrel that is up
a little under one percent on the
session joining me today is Victoria
scholar head of investment and
interactive investor Victoria good to
see you uh let's start with shell
obviously a very very uh widely followed
stock the share price hasn't really
moved too much on this I thought it was
quite a significant announcement
yeah me too not such a huge move in the
shares but certainly some significant
announcements most notably to try and
attract investors uh to the stock by
returning cash to shareholders through
this increase to its dividend of 15
although some analysts were penciling in
an increase of something more like 38
about a month ago and it's also
increasing its share buyback program
it's also got ambitious uh goals to
reduce operating costs and capital
expenditure and it's sticking to its
climate targets although it is keeping
its oil output unchanged so uh perhaps
for those climate activists who were
storming its AGM just recently they're
not going to be too happy about this
development and it comes after a similar
move from BP which scaled back its
emission targets earlier in the year but
like you say it's the capital markets
day it's time for the new CEO or
relatively new CEO while show on uh to
come to the fore and set out his goals
for how he sees the company and it seems
as though the goal is to try and
position itself for this shift towards
Renewables but still benefit from any
ongoing demand for oil over the next few
years
now obviously entertain has sold off on
the back of this announcement late last
night that it's buying a big Polish
gaming business is that just an
automatic Mark done to reflect the fact
that there's a whole Welter of new stock
on the on the market or is is the market
just not very happy with this deal
I think it's probably the former you
know it's a 750 million pound deal it's
issuing new shares and it includes 450
million pounds worth of cash for this
acquisition and often we see that the
purchasers in a Big M A Deal tend to see
their shares decline uh after a deal and
then the targets tend to go up and
that's exactly the price action that
we've seen today we're then turned down
by about 10 while STS up by uh about 10
to 15 and we know that inorganic growth
is a huge marker of this sector we've
seen so many uh Acquisitions over recent
years and this one is to try and bolster
entertains presence in Eastern Europe
particularly in Poland
Victoria what did you make of the
trading update from Robert Walters this
morning I mean we keep hearing it's a
really tight labor market that was born
out in the uh data yesterday you think
these would be good times for
recruitment firms
well on the one hand we have this very
tight labor market yesterday we saw that
employment grew quite significantly we
saw that sharp increase in wage growth
but on the other hand in that report we
actually saw that uh job vacancies have
been falling for 11 consecutive months
so there's some sort of conflicting
Dynamics when you uh kind of dig deep
into that uh data and I think what this
Fallen vacancy suggests is that
businesses are very cautious about their
hiring plans particularly when it comes
to taking on people on full-time uh
contracts instead they're looking at
temporary staff to try and plug those
holes amid the uncertain economic
backdrop from inflation from sluggish
growth and other pressures as well
Rising interest rates for example so
we've seen that a lot of companies have
become a lot more cautious about hiring
uh we've seen hiring freezes we've seen
lots of job Cuts as well as that
macroeconomics uncertainty starts away
and that's really been reflected by the
slide we've seen in Robert waters's
shares today and that profit warning now
obviously we get a policy decision from
the U.S federal reserve this evening
what are you looking out for
well this is really interesting because
we've had a whole host of aggressive
rate hikes since March of 2022 from the
fed and just yesterday we had that uh
Improvement in the inflation picture
coming down to four percent so now it's
all about the FED Skip it's going to
likely miss uh this meeting in terms of
another rate hike uh keeping rates on
pause today but that's certainly not the
end of the rate hiking cycle and I think
that's what we're going to hear from uh
Jay Powell in the rhetoric today that
while we may not see a hike today that
doesn't mean that hikes are over and
they're just going to be watching the
data closely uh monitoring what's going
on in terms of the inflation backdrop
because although the headline CPI
inflation figure has come down to four
percent if we look at the pce prices
data which is the fed's preferred
measure of inflation that's still at 4.7
so that's sharply above that two percent
Target so there is still some way to go
for the FED but of course it is a fine
Balancing Act it doesn't want to in a
advertently tip the US economy into a
recession but it still wants to keep a
lid on those price pressures
all right Victoria gotta leave it there
good to see you as ever thank you
now Barbie has been around for so long
it's perhaps surprising that she hasn't
featured in her own movie until now
Barbie the movie hits Cinemas next month
starring Margot Robbie and Ryan Gosling
the doll has been manufactured since
1959 by the American toy company Mattel
in on Crites is Mattel's chief executive
and executive producer of the new movie
I'm gonna be speaking to him in just a
moment but here's a clip to what your
appetite
cold shower falling off my roof And my
heels are on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway it looks Enon very good to see
you this morning
um you have an entertainment industry
background of course you previously see
her vendor mall I guess this is a
natural progression for you is it well
we've been on a journey at Mattel to try
to transition from being a toy
manufacturing company that was making
items to become an IP company that
manages franchises and this movie is
very much part of this journey and how
we transform our company Agatha you've
got another dozen or so movies in the
pipeline that's right in addition to
Bible we have 14 other movies in
development with stars like like um uh
many that I should mention but Tom Hanks
is one Vin Diesel is another we're
producing a matchbox movie with sky
dance that made many exciting action
films like Top Gun and Mission
Impossible so we're collaborating with
some of the most prolific filmmakers of
Our Generation which is a great place to
be and in terms of the intellectual
properties that you own I mean obviously
you have a vast range of assets which
are the ones that you feel are most
under exploited and potentially most
ripe for this sort of treatment well
we're on one of the most prolific
portfolios of film of Children and
Family entertainment franchises in the
world and that gives us exciting
opportunities to continue to evolve as a
company think of Hot Wheels American
Girl Uno Matchbox Masters of the
Universe Monster High Thomas the Tank
and many many more so we can go on and
on and on this is an exciting
opportunity for us to transform as a
company outside of the toy aisle what's
interesting though is that I'm in the
movie The Barbie Movie is clearly not
just aimed at children I mean you're
going for an adult audience as well
that's right the Barbie movie is a big
bold comedy with heart about
self-discovery and empowerment it brings
together fashion and music
self-deprecation humor and iconic
cultural moments and it will speak to
audiences of all demographics the Barbie
fans of course but many beyond that so
this is a real driver broadening the
customer base a big part of it is the
continued evolution of Barbie as a brand
and part of our own franchise management
strategy Barbie the Barbie movie will
re-contextualize the way people think of
Barbie and how much Barbie has evolved
as a global brand I mean a lot of people
have issues with Barbie and say to
portrays women in an unrealistic way are
you trying to address any of that
through the movie well the the brand has
evolved Barbie today is a flag carrier
for diversity and inclusivity Bobby
represents the work for the eyes of
children and as a brand Barbie has more
than 170 different representations more
than 200 careers and the purpose the
brand purpose is to inspire the
Limitless potential in every girl and
this will very much be brought together
in the movie and I gather the the Mattel
CEO plays a part in this as well
that's right I can say that Will Ferrell
can get away with a lot more that I can
we have slightly different leadership
styles but I'm a big fan of will ever
since the Zoolander days I'm a big fan I
can't wait to see that in particular
more broadly I mean Mattel was in a it's
fair to say it was in a spot of bother
when you became CEO what made you want
to take the job
on Mattel is one of the most iconic
corporate in America and in many ways
around the world we have an important
product we do important things and as a
company we have real societal impact
represented by Our Brands I was very
much attracted by the opportunity to
work at Mattel to lead a transformation
and we have impact on on our consumers
obviously you've de-emphasized the
manufacturing and you are steering it
towards more an intellectual property
asset like business if if you like did
you actually have to sort of think down
and think at the outset is this this is
the way out for the of this company's
problems
you know one of the most important
realizations for us is that people who
buy our product are not just consumers
they are fans
and once you realize you have an
audience many opportunities become self
uh uh self-ob obvious evident and and
the opportunity for us is to expand our
business beyond the toy aisle we're not
we love the toy business it's a great
place to be but the opportunity for
material given the portfolio that we own
is to expand beyond the toil into
content such as film and television
consumer product and merchandise digital
experiences and all of it as part of our
mission to create Innovative products
and experiences that Inspire entertain
and develop children through play and
has the shareholder base changed much
since you became CEO of people buying
into this vision
we believe so the company continues to
evolve this is a multi-year
transformation strategy financially we
achieve tremendous progress we recently
became investment grade we're launching
our first movie we recently won back the
Disney Princess and Frozen line which is
an important opportunity for us to
continue to continue to expand our
business and we're very confident and
excited about our journey ahead you know
very good to see this morning thanks
very much indeed for sparing the time
and good luck with the movie thank you
so much
our regular viewers will know that we've
been reporting from London Tech week
throughout this week here on Ian King
live in particular the discussion on the
capabilities of AI while chat GPT is one
of the best known AI applications Out
There It Is by no means the only one the
software Consulting and Cloud technology
giant IBM is about to launch a new
version of Watson its data analytics
processor with the aim of helping
clients make more use of their data
using AI well joining me now I'm very
pleased to say live from the United
States is Rob Thomas who's the senior
vice president of software and chief
commercial officer at IBM Rob very good
to see this morning how will this new
product what's the next differ from
previous offerings
Ian great to be with you thank you for
having me we are at an incredibly
exciting time where businesses know they
need to do something with AI but they're
unsure of what to do we have launched
Watson X which is a platform for
building Ai and just as importantly
governing AI it's a big difference in
how we're approaching this which is not
just can you get AI working for your
business but can you do it in a way that
is safe that you understand how
decisions are being made that accurate
decisions are being made we think it's
the perfect time to be delivering Watson
X
so what would a typical application be
for what's an X
every client comes back to three use
cases three different ways to use it
number one customer service every
company has customers they want a better
way to serve them in an automated
fashion that's number one two is the
broad category of what I would call
digital labor how you automate
repetitive tasks think of these as back
office tasks where you're doing the same
thing over and over again and third is
it automation really automating how you
run your own technology or it systems
every client that I talk to those one or
one of the three use cases that they
typically start with
now your CEO recently said he expects as
much as 30 percent of back office jobs
to be replaced by AI how rapidly do you
think that will happen
I think the key Point here is is on a
forward-looking basis companies probably
won't need to hire as many people in the
future as they would have before because
we've used AI to make their existing
employees more productive I could see
that starting to happen even inside of
the next 12 to 18 months because you can
get up and running really fast with
Watson X that's a big difference from
before since you asked where sometimes
it was a very long Consulting type
engagement now as a platform you can get
up and running very fast which means you
can start to defer hiring and drive more
productivity in your Workforce really
effective immediately
but what is very interesting though is
that IBM yourselves you have put a
freeze on on hiring in uh posts that you
think could be potentially replaced by
AI relatively rapidly
I would maybe slightly correct that we
haven't Frozen hiring we're hiring
aggressively the type of roles that
we're hiring for yes that has changed
because when you can use automation to
do some of these other tasks we can now
Focus all of our hiring on things like
Quantum Computing which is a big Focus
for IBM deep AI skills which continues
to be a focus so it really changes the
the dimension and the profile for what
we're in the market hiring great thanks
for clarifying that
um there's a lot of talk right now in
the air about regulation can it
meaningfully happen
I think it's going to be necessary the
question is in what form consumer AI you
mentioned you know things that are
happening in consumers Enterprise search
I think we need some regulation for that
because in those instances you're using
publicly available data sometimes
personal data I think that needs to be
considered the use cases I'm talking
about are more narrow domains where
you're saying we're going to work with
this company with their confidential
data
I'm not sure that we need to regulate
that so I think the key regulation
challenge is how do we protect consumers
and how do you distinguish that from AI
in a business which is a completely
different task
it's also a big challenge for employers
though isn't it because I mean if I'm an
employer I want to be sure that my my
staff are using AI appropriately and not
using it in an unethical way
this comes back to why with Watson X
we've said trusted scalable adaptable
this is what it means to put AI to work
in your business and the most important
thing is can I trust the decisions that
are being made there's this phenomena in
consumer AI that's called hallucination
where you're getting answers that don't
really make sense
no business will accept that so with
Watson X governance we ensure that
you're going to get accurate answers
you're going to be able to explain how
the answer was made even to the point of
being able to talk to a regulator to say
this is why the AI made the decision
that it did I think that's going to be
really critical for businesses well
before I let you go over to see uh Rishi
sunak the UK prime minister said he
wants the UK to to be a global player in
in regulation is he uh is he onto
something here is it going to be even
possible to coordinate regulation
globally
I think it's going to be hard to predict
what each government may decide to do
what I would say is we believe in an
open approach to AI we don't believe in
a single proprietary AI model we believe
this is going to be about multi-models
running on multiple clouds we are would
love to work with the UK government and
and we actually have some discussions
going right now where we can work with
them to deliver an open environment for
using AI in a responsible way and the
governments that I talk to around the
world I think that's the approach
they're going to want they're not going
to want one model dictated to them
they're going to want an open approach
use open source bring the best
capabilities from Enterprises companies
around the world we can do that we look
forward to partnering with governments
all around the world
all right Rob we have to leave it there
thanks for joining me today and
especially at such an unsociable hour of
your time do appreciate it thank you Ian
[Music]
try and have a look at this morning's
business pages and the financial time
splashes its print edition with the
warning yesterday from the bank of
England Governor Andrew Bailey during
which he admitted to peers that
inflation is taking a lot longer than
expected to come down the ft's
influential Lex column says that the
banks struggle to control inflation is
partly a consequence of its own failure
to predict its rise and persistence the
Ft also reports on its front page that
JP Morgan is terminating its
relationship with OD Asset Management
making it the last of the big Banks to
cut ties with the firm in the wake of
sexual misconduct allegations against
its founder Crispin Odie well that story
makes the lead in the business pages of
the times which also reports on
yesterday's moves in the marketing
guilts UK government bonds on the back
of yesterday's robust wages data the
yield on two-year guilds yesterday hit
its highest level since the financial
crisis in 2008. well the Daily Telegraph
leads its business pages with that story
reporting that Downing Street has
ordered Banks to protect struggling
homeowners is from soaring mortgage
costs as markets bet that interest rates
could hit almost six percent by the end
of the year the telegraph also reports
that up to 13 000 drivers in the Euless
and congestion charge databases have
been warned that their data was stolen
by Russian hackers in a Cyber attack on
Transport for London well joining me to
talk about uh some of these stories is
through some lunches Group business
editor at the Daily Mail and mail on
Sunday Ruth good to see you this morning
um you've actually picked out a
different story here in the Ft which is
uh the appearance before MPS yesterday
of Ray Newton Smith the cbi's new
director General
uh yeah that that that's right so
um one of the
um very interesting things about the CBI
which as we know has been fighting for
its life after a series of um very
unsavory and quite serious allegations
has been the lack of transparency that
it's had about its its members so it's
been strangely unwilling to say how many
members it's had so it it actually has
so so when they presented
um last week the vote of confidence in
them with a 93 majority is as a kind of
landslide
um victory in fact we now discover that
out of only 371 people that voted if you
take the whole membership which we
learned yesterday is one thousand two
hundred actually that support from less
than one in three of its members which
is rather less impressive as a mandate
to to go forward
um so it does continue to raise
questions about the CBI and the role it
can play and whether really given what
we now know about the level of support
that it garnered it can claim to be the
authoritative voice of British business
which it was what it wants to claim yeah
do you think it's going to ride this
storm out roof
I think the jury's very much out I think
we'll discover that a bit later on in
the year
um people have got their memberships
coming up for Renewal so a big issue is
going to be whether those companies
actually do decide to renew or not
um we've yet to learn really whether
they've won back the era of government
and indeed the labor party that's
crucial for the survival of the CBI
there are also some quite bigger knowns
we don't know who's going to be the new
president to take over from Brian
McBride the current president he said
that he's standing down by the um but
with well within the next year
um so we don't know who's taking over we
also don't know what's happening um in a
couple of people who have been in the
spotlight have said that they might or
hinted that they might take action
against the CBI so there are a lot of
question marks there hanging over its
future and other organizations like the
British Chambers of Commerce which are
jostling to try and steal the cbi's
clothes so um I think it's very much an
open question and of course the bigger
question in the really longer term is
can the CBI actually attract completely
new members as well as keeping the ones
it's gotten and
um you know bringing back into the fold
the ones that are recently left and it
actually attract new tech firms to join
and I think very much though we don't
know the answer to those questions yeah
very good point you make there Ruth now
well you've also picked on a story in
the times which is something we've
talked about on this program a lot The
Runaway success of the Japanese stock
market this year
yeah so uh it's quite the story uh the
the Nikkei yesterday went over
um 33 000 it's the
um highest it's been for 33 years so a
nice bit of numerical symmetry there
um why is that happening well investors
seem to be falling back in love with
Japan a little bit they've been
progressed by Toyota on electric cars
there's a bit more optimism around
SoftBank which
um as we know one of the biggest Tech
investors in Japan so it's all beginning
to feel a bit more a bit more Rosy I
think there's also an element of
um Japan benefiting from disillusion
around the US and and some other markets
where there's an awful lot of political
turmoil and uncertainty so people are
looking elsewhere of course
um people with long memories would
remember
um the last time that we all got very
influenced by Japan in the 1980s it did
all end in tears and in fact the Nikkei
isn't yet above its peak which was
reached in 1989 so I just say that to to
put a little bit of perspective around
it all but the times as you say they've
called it the Land of the Rising index I
suppose that was just irresistible as a
headline really wasn't it yeah
absolutely remember it well 1989 no uh
Ruth uh shout out to your paper you've
been running a campaign on bringing back
that free shopping for tourists and
you've got a couple of new names to uh
who've called to the colors today
that that's right so uh bosses at
Heathrow are saying that they would like
to see the vat free shopping
um reinstated for tourists we have seen
post pandemic
um that we have had visitors spending by
visitors has got back
um to pre-covered levels in the UK but
in other countries such as um Italy and
France it's done much better than that
so it's increased on what it was before
and a lot of people think really that
that is to do with this inability now to
reclaim vat so it was under the Rishi
soon act chancellorship in 2021 that
that was scrapped
um the treasury says it's costing 2
billion a year other analysts say
actually there would be a net benefit to
reinstating it
um just because of the increased
spending overall now what what's what's
very nice I think today is we've seen
Britain's um first Master Savile Row
Taylor A lady called Catherine Sergeant
she's also backed our campaign there are
now 200 um businesses and and Business
Leaders backing that
um and um I I don't know if you've ever
been in her shop
um I I did interview her once and and um
you know it's remarkable and really
great to see a woman doing so
brilliantly in a male-dominated field
but she says a lot of her International
clients are now going to Milan or Paris
instead which is a great shame it really
is now before I let you go Ruth we were
speaking to Enon Crites the CEO of
Mattel earlier on and who's that lurking
in the background on your desk is that
business editor Barbie
that certainly is I'm really glad you
asked me that so so a friend of mine um
gave me business editor Barbie
um about a year and a half ago I think
she's fabulous she's got pride of place
on my desk I would have loved to have
been given her when I was a little girl
when I was a little girl I used to go
around with notebooks and pens writing
stories about things
um so obviously I was I was always quite
keen on getting into journalism from an
early age I think it's brilliant that
Barbie's being modernized and and great
that she has so many careers I didn't
realize quite how many
anyways let's have a look
hahaha
so her hair is a little bit of a mess I
should have I should have given her a
better hairdo
um but here she is with her press pass
and uh yeah looking looking fabulous
absolutely brilliant Ruth lovely to see
us ever thanks for joining me today
thank you thanks Ian bye-bye
back to TV presenter Barbie Now TV
presenter Ken if you like returning to
London Tech week now and on Monday Rishi
sunak addressed the conference promising
to ensure UK Tech firms had access to
the finance they needed well this
morning the Secretary of State for
science Innovation and Technology Chloe
Smith is making the keynote address in
London I've been speaking to about what
more the government can do to ensure
that tech companies in the UK thrive
the UK is a really thriving environment
for Tech and you can see this reflected
in for example new research that
suggests we've taken the crown from New
York for development and deployment of
tech but for that to continue to be true
the government will be playing its part
to continue to support startups for
example we've had the chancellor
addressing London text week Tech week
talking about how we can work with the
likes of HSBC Innovation Banking and so
much more to ensure that there is the
access to finance that will be needed
and then other tools to continue to help
firms to grow so that's the startup
aspect and the scale-up aspect now we
also see business confidence Rising this
is critically important I think and you
see for example research from PWC and
also Deloitte suggesting that this is
coming to sharpened levels and that's
exactly as we want it to be because the
message here is that Britain is open for
business London Tech week is a
demonstration of that and we want to
play our part to ensure that every part
of the system can you continue to grow
into Thrive you put your finger on a
very crucial point there the UK is great
at starting tech companies but getting
them to scale up is something we really
fail at how do you stop startups from
selling out to the U.S tech Giants the
moment they they look like they might be
scalable
well and we know that it's really
important to and continue to ensure that
um uh Britain is perceived to be the
best environment to grow in and that's
why we're taking a range of actions for
example we're putting more into r d
investment and we're ensuring that
actually the tax relief system also
reflects that which is really important
but we also know that things like uh the
skills pipeline are essential and that's
why we're working to ensure that we're
we're bringing skills through schooling
and higher education that will be
suitable for the tech industry but also
actually that we're attracting uh Global
Talent so for example The Graduate Visa
is really important here because firms
can draw on graduates from the top 50
universities around the world and they
can come to the UK for two years and be
part of uh the tech ecosystem or many
other opportunities as well you
mentioned the uh support and tax release
available for tech companies it's it's
one of the common complaints that I hear
a lot is that it's great for big
corporates to attract that sort of money
it's much harder for smes to get their
hands on it
well and we we can understand that which
is why we're going to lengths to ensure
that actually there is support there for
smes and as I say which is why we it's
also why we are focusing on support
right at the very seedlings of things so
r d is incredibly important in that
um and also we are focusing on
supporting uh for example spin outs and
scale-ups from the University ecosystem
not forgetting that again we are
globally leading there because we have
uh you know a number of the the very top
universities in this country all of this
together of course is also why it's
really important that we have the
department that I leave the department
for science Innovation and technology
which is dedicated to supporting this
country to be a science and technology
super
and that means supporting the very very
smallest to continue to grow to take
their Amazing Ideas and why because
those ideas are going to change lives
that's what we're really interested in
and you see that reflected I think at
the stands at London Tech weekend much
more now the PM said last week he wants
the UK to be a global leader in the
regulation of artificial intelligence
what's that regulation going to look
like
well you will have heard him say also at
uh at Tech week that we want to be able
to lead domestically with a
pro-innovation agile regulatory
framework that will allow us to gain the
benefits of artificial intelligence
whilst also ensuring that people can
take confidence in these safety and
responsibility or applied uh to that
technology but he's also set out quite
rightly that we have an opportunity to
lead globally so to lead domestically
but also to lead globally and there the
UK is going to be hosting the first
summit on AI safety and I think this is
really exciting because again it's about
opening up the potential of this
technology but doing so in a safe and
responsible way that allows people to
take trust in it and thirdly what we
want to see out of all of that is the
application of these uh these these huge
pools of potential to the benefit of
British citizens and we'll see that
through Public Services it's a really
any point in attempting regulation of
this kind and without getting the likes
of China involved
well first of all let's be clear
actually in terms of Regulation We are
following the approach that we've set
out in our AI white paper in terms of
the UK which is to uh which is to draw
on our existing regulators and to have
an agile and flexible framework that
will allow us to keep Pace with the
technology which is moving very very
fast internationally I think what we're
looking at is is guard rails I would
characterize it more as the guard rails
that will be needed to allow governments
and the firms the frontier labs and
others to work together to bring uh to
bring this extraordinary technology to a
place where it can be trusted in for
being safe and responsible in the
European Parliament of course has its
own pretty well Advanced AI Bill going
through the process now I mean this
isn't this an issue where brexit has
been a real handicap wouldn't have been
we have been better working with the
European Parliament on this
I don't think this is a brexit issue at
all I think that's a red herring if you
don't mind me saying so the key point is
that we are able to set out what we
think is the right approach for Britain
and as I've said we think that needs to
be a pro-innovation agile approach we
can see some drawbacks in running too
fast to legislate here because actually
the technology is moving much more
swiftly than legislators could right now
so we think what we're doing is the
correct approach in terms of domestic
regulation now going again to the
international scene though we need to
work together and I was only uh just
last week at the oecd talking to many
European partners and we very much share
a view here which is that we have to
work together as like-minded allies and
we can and we will we'll be using for
like the oecd like the G7 and continuing
to talk with our European friends and
neighbors as well as many others to be
able to bring that about and looking
more broadly at the tech sector Tech
Nation helped develop the likes of
deliveroo ocado monzo you've just cut
its funding why was that
we are working together with a whole
range of Partners through the ecosystem
I can't comment on any particular
individual funding deal I don't really
think you'd expect me to do so but the
point is we have to be able to
demonstrate and come together to deliver
the the sustained position of the UK
being a leader in Tech now we are
already very well established in doing
so for example you look at the rate of
unicorn formation here in the UK and
actually it's uh you know better than
that of France and Germany combined and
a few other indicators as well that
demonstrate how the UK is the tech
capital of Europe now you of course are
in this capacity is maternity cover for
Michelle donran how's this working I
mean there's nothing really been tried
like this in government in the past well
it is still it is still quite historic
it must be said it's the it's the second
only the second ever time this has been
done at the cabinet table and the first
in a policy department so for me I think
it's a really important opportunity and
actually when the call came through I
was delighted to take the role not only
because the subject matter is so
thrilling and so profound and so
compelling but also because I want to
see maternity leave be normal and be
successful at these highest levels of
government the way I'm approaching that
is I'm sure as any uh person in any
organization would to be able to deliver
for support to a friend and a colleague
which is that I've been sitting down
with Michelle Donald to look at the
program to make sure we can sustain
delivery we know of course that actually
we're both delivering the prime
ministers very personally held
objectives as well about science and
technology so it's a really exciting
agenda we have every opportunity to make
the department for science Innovation
and Technology one of the most
Innovative places in government working
with so many partners across Tech and
science to do so and I know we're both
absolutely committed to that
well that's it from me for today there's
much more on the Scotty's mobile app and
on the website with reporting video
content and Analysis from our business
team in fact there's a piece from me up
there right now on business Empire of
Silvio Berlusconi do have a look at that
if you can I'm back at 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning hopefully on the TV
channel in the meantime thanks for
joining us today on this very special
digital only version see you tomorrow
cheerio
[Music]